so we look at Elon Musk or Conor
McGregor or Kim Kardashian and we want
the success that they have within a very
narrowly defined domain of competence
Tiger Woods the greatest golfer ever but
his dad mistreated him so much as a kid
that they had a safe word that tiger
could tell him if he'd had enough and
tiger never once said it his dad would
racially abuse him while he was on the
golf course but the question is would
you pay that price to be Tiger Woods
would you have so little self-belief
outside of the golf game that you have
the most public marriage failure that
anyone's ever seen he's on antipsychotic
drugs and being pulled over by police at
the side of the road because that's the
price you have to pay to be Tiger Woods
a lot of people I think if they were
able to see the full package they
wouldn't pay that price yeah and who
knows what price you pay for hyper
specialization you know and I learned
that looking at Power mad c-suite types
so let's see sweet types they're working
non-stop corporate lawyers in New York
they make 700 an hour but they work all
the time and there are people who are
suited for that but it isn't obvious
that that's for everyone or that it's
even desirable